Is everything okay?
You seem a little pensive.
>> [SOUND] Yeah I'm just thinking.
You know choosing a back end stack for
an app is a huge decision, and
I'm definitely convinced that Firebase
is a good option given how easy it is to
set up, but is it the best option for
the project?
There are other database
solutions out there.
I know there's no SQL and SQL Solutions.
There's Oracle, there's Parse.
I guess we could even build our own
back end if we really wanted to.
So I'm just kind of wondering why
not any of those other options?
>> First of all Firebase consists of
a database and a collection of services
which is sometimes referred
to as back end as a service.
Let's look at a few other
database options, and
then compare them to Firebase.
Oracle and SQL are both examples
of relational databases.
These databases are often transaction
based with rollback functionality.
They're generally used for
larger enterprise applications requiring
a large number of read write operations.
They're not good choices for Shopping
List Plus Plus because they don't
handle real time applications natively.
Parse is similar to Firebase in
that it is a back end as a service.
It is a no SQL implementation and
uses MongoDB as its database.
For Shopping List Plus Plus
it's a better choice, but
it still requires third party support
to build real time applications.
Firebase is also implemented
as a no SQL solution
with the database being
one large JSON object.
There are not tables, or collections,
or documents like MangoDB.
Also Firebase is hosted in the cloud,
which makes it easier to access data
on any client anywhere in the world.
Finally Firebase gives you complete
control for organizing data and
changing your schema.
This offers amazing flexibility and
is great for prototyping applications.
>> So Lila while it is possible to build
a collaborative mobile applications with
either Oracle or
Parse it takes additional planning and
requires additional integration
with third party services.
Firebase implementation is
designed from the ground up for
real time and collaborative applications
like Shopping List Plus Plus.